and the eagles now could hire brian
dabal right
that he's available you know the eagles
what they did last week because they got
into it late chris
they went with all the guys for
interviews that they suspected will get
hired elsewhere and now they're kind of
moving on
to the rest of their list and i'm not
sure what they're looking for they met
with josh mcdaniels
for a fairly long period of time on
sunday they need someone who
shares the organization's vision for
carson wentz and will fix carson wentz
because that's the one thing that's
become clear in the last week
the eagles want to find a way to keep
carson wentz and get the most
out of him does he want a long haul does
he want to stay there mike
well if peterson's gone maybe he does
because that was the report
from mortensen that the relationship
between peterson
and wentz was fractured beyond repair
well peterson's gone now
so for similar reasons though to what
the texans are dealing with and we're
going to talk about that in a second
you better make sure that carson wentz
is on board with whoever that means
you don't want that to be an issue where
when says nah no thanks you had your
chance to hire somebody i would have
liked i don't want that guy well or just
make sure he's on board in general like
we're gonna hire a coach they're like
hey we're hiring a coach because we
wanted to work with carson wentz
and then he's in a call 10 days later
and be like i want to be traded i don't
want to ever play in philadelphia ever
again right
they got to figure that out i you know i
have been led to believe that yes the
the doug peterson carson wentz thing was
not perfect
i don't think that was the ultimate
reason of why peterson got fired i think
it was part of it from what i've been
led to believe by people i know
attached to the situation but yeah i've
yet to hear that aspect of it and like
you said at the end of the year
carson wentz at some point is going to
have to let
let it be known be the good guy the bad
guy or whatever but he's gonna have to
put his thoughts out there and make a
stand about
what do you want to do and right now i
don't know where that goes and
uh that's going to be it it's going to
be interesting this eagle situation
bright mike what i i can't believe we're
sitting here right now
and there's two spots left and brian
dabal and eric bienemy are still out
here
i i cannot believe that i cannot and i
would almost
right now to the point where i'd go to
both of them go just sit back and wait
till next year
i do do you want to go to houston or
philly as your first head coaching job
probably not
right now right it's dicey yeah
no especially not houston philadelphia
concerns me because of the wence dynamic
and i want to be damn sure i'd want to
i'd want to truly genuinely believe in
wentz i don't want it to just be hey i
want a head coaching job
i'd have to truly believe in wentz right
wence would have to believe in me right
and that would have to be strong enough
to overcome
the reality that i'm stepping into one
of the toughest markets to be a head
coach
where like like winning that
super bowl gave those fans a taste of a
highly addictive drug
and they want another one you're right
you're right and and
and it's made it worse not better that
they have a super bowl trophy
you're right so yeah no thanks i need
hazard pay i need a six year fully
guaranteed contract with no
offset before i take that job
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports